[Music]
during the first lockdown there was
still motivation to fight but now it's
fading faster and faster
the light at the end of the tunnel is
what the restaurateurs lack
we all like it
assistance programs need to be greatly
simplified and disbursements must be
significantly
accelerated people don't need to wait
months for payments and be at even
greater risk
they've had over a year to work out this
plan in detail but it still doesn't work
we've applied for financial assistance
for november and december for two
businesses i own
we're talking about 130 000 euro for
november 160
000 for december i received 60 000 euro
and i need to cover the costs of two
companies and staff
part-time benefits can also be applied
for but you will not receive it until
three months later this means that first
you have to pay everything out of your
[Music]
pocket
this policy has not changed for a year
of course
they need to learn new things other ways
out are emerging
including through new technological
advances
you cannot stay put and hope that
everything will be fine
the bundestag elections in september are
also likely to play a role
nobody wants to make a mistake because
in the end you may not be elected
but this is not about politics not about
federal politics or
electoral mandates but about our society
as a whole
especially about the event industry and
catering establishments
because they are bursting at the seams
you